[Music]
all right so how much of this then to
you is the micro verse the macro because
I sense you're actually conceding a
little bit of ground in that you don't
think that Michael is going to murder
anyone but that you think that for
society as a whole so that is a that's
right because if eighty ISM is okay what
I say dividing them over is the legal
statement
bed bed cases or exceptional cases make
bad law whatever it is I of course there
will be individuals to look my favorite
analogy seatbelts save lives is that a
generalization it is true is it true in
every single case of course not
sometimes you die because you wore a
seatbelt a joke you you couldn't get out
of a burning car or whatever so do if
there are two people one they're both
moral Michael Shermer is moral this
guy's moral the guy who thinks God will
judge him for his behavior I trust in
the final analysis more then the person
who only has to answer to his own
conscience I am NOT a big believer in
humanity unless the guy says Allahu
Akbar just before you're right right
that's not that's not the God I'm
talking about it so what is it we had an
imam here so then all right so fine so
then I'll give you some out Sato was an
atheist
I didn't saddle to you with Mao Mao
killed eighty million people
well nothing I don't address that in
your video don't you that if they had
replaced with religion was a different
yes was an atheist religion yeah of
course but that's what that one is
religion is I was an atheist rule it
back what I was but but that's not
people don't kill in the name of atheism
they kill a name of some ideology or
whatever right or racist or I understand
that doesn't matter though you've not
anyway the God and I found if you
believe in God now kill you I don't want
to sell you with the ISIS thing I'm just
saying if we had an imam here and he
said well we believe in Revelation also
and ours came in the seventh century and
and you know yes that's fine ok so I'm
telling you that the the God that you
and I are talking about was revealed in
the Old Testament that's the God we're
talking about that another man makes
another claim
may he live and be well it is irrelevant
to my argument okay there are people who
believe God God has you know twelve
heads and as a turtle I can't deal with
that I'm dealing with the God who gave
the Ten Commandments okay but so that
though how then do you square the people
I mean remove the three monotheistic
religions and imagine another guy who
believes in a turtle with twelve head
but just other religious just other you
know polytheistic religions that have
existed for a long time that do have a
basis in Morales Buddhism yeah and I
think it's terrific where they I don't I
don't think that the Buddha would have
argued that morality is objectively real
I I've studied Buddhism I'm not a
Buddhism scholar but that anyway he he
sought inner enlightenment the Buddhist
project is not to make the world moral
it is to have the individual transcend
his ego and this great value in that but
it's a different aim so so what do you
think about the Microverse macro yes I I
know I know you pretty well and I'm
pretty sure this thing's not gonna end
with you murder
well I think that I do think there's
some legitimacy to the argument that on
a societal whole everyone just starts
listening to the thing in there forever
people are kind of whack Lord and are
going to do crazy things when we have
evidence because we've already just
mentioned Isis and all kinds of it
that's right what do you think about
that the small you know the individual
radical acting out it's a perfect point
so you and I are both fans of the
founding fathers and the Constitution
and so on and I was just we're just
talking about the Hamilton biography and
what a genius this guy was Jefferson son
I don't think they were channeling Moses
or Jesus of the Old Testament they were
channeling Hobbes Locke and Rousseau era
saw all the great philosophers who came
before that thought what's the best way
to a structure society that we attenuate
these inner demons and accentuate the
better angels all right we need you know
three structures you know three you know
judicial I'm sorry the branches or three
branches of government are if we don't
really use them anymore
that's not need the you know we need you
know we needed the Supreme Court and we
need local court we need a rule of law
we need a police military basically all
that was a sort of a science or
technology of social structure how can
we do this because people will
act on their own best self-interest
that's why we need checks and balances
and so on and and that didn't happen in
very many places in the world and
historically you know only a couple of
times does that happen so it's a unique
experiment in a way the social contract
let's call it that is a transcendent
objective form of moral legal social
system by which we're going to live so
that we all flourish and survive and
flourish and have a more moral lives and
and it works pretty well even though
like in your seatbelt example doesn't
always work but it works better than all
the other systems and to me to me it
feels transcended in the sense it's not
my opinion it's not your opinion you
know these guys set this up it's been
tweaked and tweaked and tweaked it's
like an experiment you know that's why
Jefferson called what we're doing an
experiment a lot we're running the
experiment tweaked the variables have
another election tweak the variables the
Supreme Court says now we're going to do
this that let's change that that to me
feels objective in the sense of it's
outside of me and you it's not just
opinion right I don't know why it feels
objective because they they were
opinions they were great opinions we
both adore these people but they were
opinions I just have to take issue
though that and this this one is not a
this country and everything else we
spoke about this not an opinion issue
this is is a factual question and I just
factually disagree every single one of
the founders except for Thomas Paine was
a god-centered person who believed that
without God the American experiment
would not work Washington said it in his
famous inaugural address in or as
farewell address I should say where your
periphery Singh and he is a fool fool
who thinks that we can have a moral
society without religion Jefferson wrote
the the Declaration of Independence we
are endowed by our Creator because if
the Creator doesn't endow us with
inalienable rights there are in the Navy
a noble rights well of course as you
know Jefferson was a deist not really a
no but a deist
in those days is not what these theists
today means you believe that a creator
in that end of the issue they all
believed in a providential God who
interfered in human events Benjamin
Franklin
his autobiography wrote I believe in a
God who works in history and who judges
all people and in a Harrier here after
Franklin and I have the same exact
theology he wasn't an Orthodox Christian
most of them were not that's true but
they were all God centered and the God
was the god of of the of the Bible so
you can separate that sort of God
centered view that they had from the
fact that they very clearly wanted
separation of church and state but I'm
reassured that the overreaching power
not only what they kind of they had Atma
but they had a bigger fear in a society
that would abandon God is the root of of
rights and and human worth that was
there that was as big a fear as any
by the way separation of church and
state as I am we all know what it's
worth just noting is in one letter that
Jefferson wrote it's not in the
Constitution or anything else actually
when my favorite moments in the in the
Hamilton biography is where he later
asked how come he didn't put God in the
Federalist Papers in the Constitution
when he said I forgot and I'm not an
attorney now the biographer goes this
from a man who never forgot anything he
didn't forget it because it's not an
argument you can't make you can't make
an argument to your fellow politicians
or whatever you're trying to kick it was
this supposition of the founders that
people would believe that that rights
came from religion and that the Bible
would be the moral educated tool of
their children Lincoln would rarely went
to church had a Bible on his nightstand
and everyone says he read it every day
well why do you think they put in
endowed by our Creator oh do you think
it was just sort of a linguistic trick
in a way to I I think it's language they
put in just to kind of reinforce the
point like putting in god we trust' on
the money which was done to in the 50s
to counter the atheism of communism and
I think also to your point I think there
was a sense in the founding fathers that
we can't police everybody it's a big
open country we can't have you know
policemen on every corner and so on it
would be good if everyone had an
internal policeman exactly I totally
agree with mine I think we need that
anymore in the sense that okay now we
had we're better
or kinder today oh absolutely right the
American experiment is unraveling I
don't think so
I okay fine you have more optimism about
what I'm sure you should be super
optimistic the Republicans are running
the shows yeah what a pile of you have
bigger fears related to your media well
okay look all I know is 50% of kids
according to Pew do not believe in free
speech for hate yeah I think that's a
problem where we are is Ray on it oh I
know I agree that's my point yes I think
that the American Revolution is being
undone equality is supplanting Liberty
the French Revolution is defeating the
American Revolution all right you know
what let's hold that to the end because
I think that's where we can all sort of
come around and tie this nicely together
so but just circling back I'm glad you
brought it to the to the political part
of this when I see all these people on
the right that often talk about God
publicly you know politicians would say
Ted Cruz or something so also say you
know I'm a constitutional conservative
and I'm an absolutist now I believe the
Constitution is probably the greatest
political document ever made I wish we
could be governed by those three
branches of government that we're
supposed to be I wish we were doing
things the way that they are written
unfortunately we're not for a series of
reasons but do you think that so you
just don't think that that would be
enough the resolution I don't would not
be enough and the founders would have
said it's not enough to that's that's my
point it's not it's my opinion obviously
but I believe it was their opinion too
they understood that human nature is so
anarchic that without believing that I
am morally responsible to a moral god
the society will fall apart and I think
they're right I would prefer to believe
that people can internalize moral values
such that intrinsically it's good not to
do this just because full stop not
because I'm being watched
there's an eye on the sky not because
I'll get rewarded later but because it's
just good would you prefer that people
work hard without getting paid well it
depends what they're doing and anything
a waiter it doesn't matter now factory
yltp you
yeah exactly okay but but so wait wait
wait why is that why is that less why in
it because weren't you not moral work is
not morality it's a different it's not
that a different realm of behavior oh
you know I I'll never forget it made a
big impact on me before I got married at
32 so my whole 20s I was a bachelor and
I knew nothing about marriage because
nobody knows anything about marriage so
you get married and and so I talked to
married men I'm a friend who's a married
guy so he's a good-looking guy he was an
ex-marine television guy so I said to
him one day said Bob just curious we
were close enough did you ever cheat on
your wife and he said you know what then
it's funny you should ask because
obviously I gotta know you know I'm
tempted I travel a lot it's tempting and
he said you know I'm not at all
religious I you know I I never I never
go to church or synagogue and but I
gotta tell you I know this is gonna
sound funny gonna laugh at me but I
really do believe God is watching and he
said do not commit adultery i I think
that between for forgive me for being as
crass as it sounds between the penis and
the conscience the penis will usually
win and and and having God's sake
control your organ is is more powerful
you know I used to be in a band in
Brooklyn called between the penis and
the conscience were you here by you and
I know that was a really a I was making
an allusion looking at yeah but so
jumping from that to you basically
because you you believe that eventually
will self-regulate ourselves into into
some goodness sort of you think we could
we could have the laws of the land that
we have right now and we simply don't
need the weapon if the founding fathers
had some yeah regardless of what the
value about I mean we've already been
doing this for centuries
you know the whole structure the whole
moral progress of Western civilization
that I have written about Steve Pinker
is written about so it comes about from
this idea that we can actually set up
political and economic and social
systems in a way it nudges people toward
being better and they don't think Europe
is committing suicides as locally with
the God
I'm just curious because you mean
because of the immigrant yes yeah yes
and because it no longer believes in
itself yes because all right so that
repeating categories are based on this
enlighten on these like right human at
it yes the godless universe ceases to
believe in itself the Western world no
no but if the problem is these super
religious immigrants that are from no
the problem is the secular in allowing
them to get in not only allowing them to
come in they don't believe they don't
believe in anything anymore
they believe in vacation time in in
maternity leave higher wages that's what
they believe it's all material I think I
think you may also mean that they don't
believe in the goodness of the society
that's all good right exactly
well as you would argue comes from God
you know I argue I argue that a will to
live even to make babies the religious
affluent have far more babies than the
secular affluent there is a massive this
is why I said earlier I came to God most
particularly because I saw the
alternative doesn't work the godless
world being created in the West in
Western Europe his bait is is
dissipating the countries are literally
disappearing people don't even have the
will to marry or the will to have babies
or the will to preserve Britain or
Germany or France that's that that's a
loss so that's why I think that the
micro macro thing is the most
interesting part of this conversation
because again I don't think you think
that my truck can't in another way up
and with all your friends and family we
live it perfectly more alive but do you
think there is something to that because
we're all what we are watching Europe
slowly crumble and I don't think anyone
knows exactly why I think I think that
is ultimately the reason well I think
the universities have crumbled godless
wisdom on an optimistic side yeah you
know most but I know I know a lot of
Germans now because my wife's from
Cologne and you know they're not just
sitting around going how can we get more
welfare and make more babies and get
more you know food style you know that's
not what the people you know they go to
work like the rest of us no no but that
is what they sit around thinking I just
had a
nice to live with us for six months he
he he described a Germany that I I
assumed and such as Germany could be
Belgium at this irrelevant that's what
that's what the materialist secular mind
thinks about his material it makes
perfect sense more of it is now in the
European Constitution I believe how much
vacation time and it is now a human
right to travel but but they didn't even
mention in the European Constitution
that Christianity had formed Europe I'm
a Jew saying this but but but I care
about truth Christianity made Europe
without Christianity you lose Europe
that's the way it is it but there's ok
so you're picking certain countries that
maybe Christianity had positive
development most Christian nations like
all the Catholic nations in South
Americans on they didn't develop all
those civil rights and equal treatment
for women and so right I'm talking there
a legend in Europe yeah so well just
like okay so it's not religion it's
something else that's going on there
well and my argument is that it's these
a life right religion it's good religion
is a bad religion and this could
prohibit a little trapdoor you're
getting I'm not a trapdoor of course
it's true what how can I argue otherwise
he would argue this good atheism and bad
atheism is good secular and bad secular
it's just why can we be allowed that
true there are people who get it wrong
there are people who do not emphasize
the Ten Commandments they emphasize 55
other things and they call themselves
religious what am I going to do I'm
unhappy about them but then how do you
know which is the better religion or the
less good religion what's the criteria
those same criteria that you would offer
I want to see your fruits yeah that's
the only thing that matters right and
the fruits of secular Europe is no more
Europe but yeah I don't think it's it's
the secular part I think there's other
factors going ok all right that's a
fairest or difference of opinion I say
well since the second world war they've
had a rather different history from
before for obvious reasons they're
killing each other less yes well they
had to do something to stop there no I
agree 109 forty you know they they gave
up they gave up they threw the baby out
with the bathwater
throughout nationalism and religion but
sort of pull back a little bit again
we're talking about what criteria we're
using a judge right and wrong okay so
when you say well it's religion
Christianity and I point out well what
about all those Catholic countries
that's the wrong that's better
no no first of all I mean when all is
said and done if I had to compare the
Catholic Uruguay to to a pre Catholic
Uruguay
I'll take Catholic Uruguay you you you
you have to believe their or you know
take the Mayans I think you believe that
in Mexico it was a step up for Mexicans
to Catholicism from Mayan ISM maybe it
may be alright so let's get out of sort
of the the real world politic of this
and we'll go a little to a slightly
higher dimension here if we can for a
moment so if God handed us these Ten
Commandments and made all these strong
arguments wouldn't there just be less
pain I mean I know this is sort of a
nice and easy one and you've written
some books on this kind of thing and
then as a Michael but it wouldn't there
just be less it seems like there's not
plenty of religious people that do all
sorts of bad things in the name of
religion it shows you the power you're
right but I don't know anybody who's
done bad things the name of the Ten
Commandments which is where I really
focus much of my religious belief on but
yes luckily it the that I that is why I
don't want to get it I don't want to
bore everybody but that is why there is
only one of the ten commandments that
God says he will not forgive and that is
doing evil in his name people call it
taking God's name in vain but that's
what it really means the Hebrews do not
carry not do not take because of exactly
your questions and your points nothing
ruins the possibility of God based
ethics as much as people who do
unethical in the name of God they that
is that you do you know who do you know
that this is unreported much there are
more atheist kids in Iran today than in
the history of
Muslim world the ayatollahs are creating
more atheists than every atheist
activist on steroids okay and it makes
perfect sense so we would argue that the
beautiful thing I between a secular
Iranian and and I had told a Ronnie and
I'll take a secular any day I told you
the fruits what about what matter to me
I'm your fruit oriented I'm fruit or
what is what is the tree producing I'm
saying a godless tree will ultimately
not produce a good world but I rather
have a good godless person than a bad
god person is that is that sort of the
irony is that in a weird way it had the
secular person or the non-believer means
a little bit of sort of the crazy
religious stuff in this case the
Ayatollah - actually that makes it
easier to breed some of the things that
you have rather than Michael Shermer
showing up in Tehran and going guys you
know I'm not going to try right it takes
it to go to a doctor but is that yet if
I run lately and yeah I think I think
that is why by the way parenthetically I
am very disappointed in in the Western
religious world there should have been a
hundred thousand rabbis priests and
ministers gather in Washington or London
or I don't care where as a protest
against all the evil done in God's name
in the world today they have sat on the
sidelines intimidated by the New York
Times which would call them Islamophobic
they are more they have more fear of the
New York Times and fear of God I would
say that is a general assessment of most
religious people Jew and Christian in
the world today
maybe we should organize a joint atheism
secularism we should end and we don't
Ted as that is exactly right and I don't
care so because we're not as llama folks
yeah no no we're evil real folks yeah my
man so I'm glad we got there because
look we could do this for hours and
hours we've done about an hour already
Roy so first off before I kind of get us
toward the final part did we miss any I
know we could dissect each video no no
we it was exactly what I imagined it was
a wonderful discussion is there anything
animal be the headway that I might have
well
and these are the great issues of all
time you know and the fact that they're
not ultimately resolvable I think hints
at how difficult they are in terms you
know the big questions is there a god
freewill determinism you know moral
right and wrong good and evil you know
the fact that we don't have universal
agreement on it like a law of physics
that you can measure everywhere tells us
these are hard problems which is why the
only way to figure out what to do is to
talk to other people especially those
who don't agree with you because that's
if you're in the echo chamber you're
only going to hear which is you just
wasting your time so how do we put that
into practice because I try to talk to
people from all over the political map
and I have here I have two people who
view but it you know perhaps the biggest
issue of all time in a very different
way and I have equal respect for both of
you and what I what I the question I get
from people all the time is well what do
we do now
because I do think people think as you
said Western Europe is crumbling I think
people think the underpinnings of
America for resilient layers are the
people are people that fear Trump the
people that fear the media like or
whatever corner you're in right here
we've had a you know the fear of Trump
is irrational okay it's just irrational
I mean we're not here for politics I and
but you raised it I just want to say you
didn't have to vote from you don't have
to support him but the this there is a
hysteria like Russian collusion it was
all hysteria like he foment
anti-semitism it was all history you
know who called in 90% of the hundreds
of threats to Jewish community centers
an American Jewish kid living in Israel
and the others that he didn't call in
were called in by a black radical who
wanted to frame his ex-girlfriend I mean
I was right you know it's all over no
nobody talks now about all the sanitized
Emmett ism in America because of Trump
you know Jenny when today they do lie
when that was happening I actually
purposely didn't tweet about it because
I saw everyone getting on board and
saying it's all Trump it's all Trump but
everything this just seems too easy I
want to wait a little bit and then of
course you end up you right so how do we
take this yeah how do we take the
richness of this and go all right we
fundamentally believe something so
different but we actually still want to
live in the same society yeah because I
don't think you guys are going well you
know even if you think that the ideas
that might go is pushed here
aren't going to be good in the long run
for your society or you think that were
allies in the course of Liberty and
that's that I want that's where I want
to liberty and freedom of speech is on
is the fundamental right that trumps all
the other well Trump's it's the basis
beneath all the other stuff we're
talking about and obviously need
interesting that you both can get there
yeah absolutely and I'm encouraged by
that as well as I'm not sure what what
you call what you're doing alternative
media to the mainstream media or you
know the internet meeting I'm all it
something different in every universe
that I'm doing okay yeah I don't I don't
know what the right word is but I really
encourage which shows like yours Joe
Rogan's
you know Sam Harris you know and these
are great shows I mean the most
interesting conversations makes that I
listen to are they're not you know in
CNN or whatever no these this is where
it's at and that this could be the
future it where even academics who are
you who are seemingly hopelessly lost
here will see like this Jordan Peterson
you know you can make more money on
patreon than from the universe maybe
that's the futures like just talking to
people like well look I know Prager
University we tell people get a free
education we will have 400 million views
this year right and the greatest single
percentage is under 35 years of age whoa
all right so then I have one final
question for you both what would you be
your greatest sell if someone that's
listening to is that that is an atheist
they've just come to that conclusion
and if they didn't want to be not
convinced they don't want you to
convince them to not but they want to be
convinced of wanting to live in the same
society as you what's the great well I
gave the argument earlier the founders
did understand that without God it's a
limited government won't work just as
you said we seemed to that was an area
of agreement it seemed to me and I don't
want to put any words in your mouth god
forbid but I said I they understood if
people feel morally accountable to God
then they don't we don't need a lot of
police we don't need a big government
government rises in the West
as as God diminishes in the West and and
in the United States or in Europe
because somebody's got a police people
somebody's got to dictate what happens
the government substitutes I don't want
big government and the the American
dream was to have limited government so
that we are free but ultimately morally
answerable to the God of the Ten
Commandments that's clever because he's
playing to the classical liberals as we
know here I work what would you be
yourself or the person that's a believer
that's watching this yeah but you'd want
to live in that same Society yeah
well I I think dr. King had it right the
the arc of the moral universe is long
but it bends towards justice
I think the origin of the bending force
has been this inculcating in all of our
thinking to make it our second nature to
be good for goodness sake full-stop
now we're a long ways from the you know
getting there
but we're better than we were half a
century ago better still than a century
ago and so I do think there's and I
think that moral arc is built into the
structure of society the way we keep
tweaking it it's like an experiment and
I think we need to keep running the
experiment and that open free dialog and
speech is the only way to keep tweaking
it in the right direction well this has
been an absolute pleasure for me so I
hope you guys have enjoyed it oh and
both agree it took us a while to get the
schedules lined up because you guys are
busy but I'm glad we did this and I hope
we can do something like this again we
can figure out some other existential
things do a great job for crack really
good I can kind of turn this way a
little you know what and I have no
reason to patronize you with but so I'm
not but you your questions events
sincere curiosity and that's a big deal
strangely I think doing something that
should be common these it should be that
well thank you for that you for coming
in and thank you guys for watching it
yes we are going to do more of these
I've got a couple interesting ones lined
up so it's yeah you know it's YouTube
back on side remember you're watching
this right now for anybody who say that
thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]